-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Jesse Eisenberg.
You and your family
live in New York.
Are you spending
the holidays here?
-No. No, we're not.
We're spending the holidays
in the Midwest
at an international
folk dancing camp.
-Okay.
-Yeah. Yeah.
You could tell I-I obviously
lost the, you know, battle
on making that decision.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-Have you done it before?
-We did it once.
We did it this summer.
It's folk dancing, you know,
from mainly the Balkans.
So, you know what that is,
of course.
-Yeah, of course. Yeah, yeah.
-Of course. It's classic.
-I didn't have
to go to school for it.
I just knew it.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You either have it inside
or not.
It's dancing.
No, but, like --
You know, so you live
in these cabins
and then, you know,
in the afternoons
you go and do these, like,
long line dancing exercises,
I guess you might call it.
And I didn't go out
for, like, the first three days
because I heard it was,
you know, dancing.
And then, I finally went out
most likely to, like,
retrieve my wife
to, like, bring her back
to, you know, reality.
And then, I discovered that
it's not so much dancing
as kind of, like, formations
and geometry and rules.
And those are three things
I love.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, in fact,
I think I love them as much
as I hate dancing, you know.
-Oh, wow.
-So then I started, like,
doing these line dances.
I found myself.
Because it's something physical,
but it requires
complete rule-following.
-Yeah.
-And to me, that's great.
-Gotcha.
-You know what I mean? Yeah.
-So no instructor
is ever, like,
"Find yourself!"?
-No. No.
-Okay.
-That's my worst nightmare.
That's what I expect
everything that's
dancing-related to be.
I remember, actually,
when my wife and I
first started dating,
she would go out
to dance clubs
and it was just completely --
I was never even asked.
-[ Laughs ]
-It was just understood,
"I'm going out dancing.
I'll probably see you
in the morning."
-[ Laughs ]
-And that was great.
-So that's wonderful
that you found
this collective thing
to do together,
which is to go
to Balkan folk dancing class.
-Balkan -- A perfect
compromise, yeah.
-You grew up in New Jersey?
-Yes.
-What was when you --
[ Cheering and applause ]
There we go.
We have some in the house.
-I would hope so.
-Always sneak through,
no matter how much
security's at the door.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, probably because
of the proximity.
-Yeah, the proximity.
-Yeah, yeah.
-What did you think was funny
growing up?
What were your...
-You know, I wrote jo--
I mean, it's weird to tell you
this because I mean, you know --
But I wrote, like, just jokes
when I was younger.
You know, I saw, recently,
in my parents' house,
in a drawer, I just had written,
like, tons and tons
of one-liners
when I was younger,
kind of Borscht Belt-y
one-liners, and they --
I was going through them
kind of horrified
'cause they were, like, really
all about one of two things.
They were either
about basketball or sex
'cause those were, like,
the two things
I was interested in.
-[ Laughs ]
-Maybe because I knew
those were the two things
that I was probably not going to
achieve in my life, you know.
[ Laughter ]
And one I achieved, you know,
a few times over the course
of a given year.
-Right. [ Laughs ]
-And the other one
I can't seem to get
a foothold in,
you know what I mean?
But anyway, those were,
like, my jokes
because I was just
obsessed with basketball
and I heard jokes about sex.
I couldn't even tell you
probably what it was.
I was 13 years old, you know.
I probably didn't even know
what I was talking about.
But that was, like --
Jokes were about sex.
I guess jokes are still
kind of about sex.
-They are still.
And then, did you also write --
You didn't write a Woody Allen-
inspired screenplay.
-I did, and then I wrote
a screenplay, yes.
When I was 16,
I wrote a screenplay
about Woody Allen.
-So you wrote it about him?
-I wrote it about Woody Allen.
Took place modern day.
But it was about him
changing his name to Woody,
which he actually did at the age
at which I wrote it,
which was, like, 16 years old.
And I wrote the script, and I
had sent it around to people
just desperately sending it out
to anybody I can find
whose address I found.
Anyway, it got to his lawyer
[ Laughter ]
and, um,
if you write something
about somebody,
the person you want to read it
is usually not, you know,
the representative,
you know, the legal counsel
of the person in question.
And I remember my dad came
in my bedroom one day,
he was like,
"I have amazing news.
We heard from Woody Allen.
We heard from Woody Allen."
He had opened the letter.
And I was like,
"That's incredible."
He was like, "Well, actually,
it's not all great news.
It's not all great news.
The great news ends that
we heard from Woody Allen."
He sent me
a cease and desist letter.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-I gotta say, there's a lot
of 16-year-olds out there
who aren't getting
cease and desist letters
from filmmakers.
-No. It's an honor just to be
rejected by him,
you know what I mean?
-Yeah, exactly.
Hey, thank you for being here.
Congrats on the show.
It's always a pleasure
to see you.
-Thank you so much.
-Have a wonderful time
at dance camp.
Jesse Eisenberg, everybody.
New episodes of FX's
"Fleishman Is in Trouble"
stream Thursdays on Hulu.
We'll be right back.